Oh far ahead I don't know cooter growl
anything I'm gonna celebrate no matter
what I'm already in celebration mode I'm
gonna enjoy this this is my first time
nominated and if I ever get nominated
again who knows but there will never be
another first time and so I'm going to
enjoy this what surprised me the most I
might be able to answer that question
better after the Oscars I had heard you
know I mean I chose to engage and going
around and supporting Dallas buyers club
in this whole season you know and and I
think one of the surprising things
actually is that we have six nominations
for the film six nominations for this
little film that we never thought we'd
get made I mean getting it made we felt
a huge victory in that and then all of a
sudden we have a real presence here in
many different places that surprised me
I remember when I read the script and
when we made it I felt like it had the
potential to be something special but as
you know there's no guarantee and that
is stuck with people I thought it could
but at that is stuck it's stuck with
people and people were shining a light
on it the Academy's shining a light on
in a huge way with those six nominations
other than that the whole process I've
had a good time doing it and I think
that has to do with the experience that
I had you know some people I had heard
how laborious it could be I'm not found
that laborious I've found it a lot to do
in place it to be but but I think I can
talk about my experience with this guy
Ron Woodruff in this film until the day
I die without getting too exhausted
though
you have been having so much fun with
clothes I mean everybody loves with love
you know not just the usual tuxedo tell
us the process now of licking out
wonderful outfits you know ones that
I've been wearing I thought there's an
inside joke after your first comment I
haven't had a good time well this season
there's a lot of opportunity to wear a
lot of nice clothes so I did say you
know what let's get some some vine suits
I found a guy off a photo shoot named
Simon I found him on a GQ shoot and I
said you know what I like what you had
laid out there the first three things
you had laid out your A's were my age I
was like yes I said you know we got a
long phone call and I said I'm gonna be
wearing a lot of nice clothes and suits
along this season some tuxedos I'd like
to always be classy but I'd like to you
know throw it off just a little bit
whether it's a tan whether it's a suitor
hat on the other night just throw off
just a little bit but also keep it
classy so that's some of the fun of an
avid thank you no thank you